this is the breaking news for the day
the lady playing Snow White
who is she's very intentionally not
particularly White
so we've been calling her sand beige
this lady who's a far left-wing
pretty insufferable lady she she's got
another hit take it away
I mean you know the original cartoon
came out in 1937 and very evidently so
um there is a big focus on her love
story
um with a guy who literally stalks her
weird
time so no prints or a different kind of
Prince we have a different approach to
what I'm sure a lot of people will
assume is a love story just because like
we cast a guy in the movie Andrew burn
up great dude
um it's uh it's one of those things that
I think everyone's gonna have their
assumptions about what it's actually
going to be but uh it's really not about
the love story at all which is really
really wonderful and whether or not she
finds love along the way is anybody's
guess until 2024.
um all of Andrew scenes could get cut
who knows it's Hollywood baby
it has to be intentional at this point
right Disney has to be trotting this
lady out probably put her through
rigorous acting training to say be as
insufferable as you possibly can be as
off-putting to our core audience as you
possibly can be
so that it will generate controversy and
people will talk about it it has to be I
have to believe that is what Disney is
doing
that makes sense that at least it's
working obviously we're talking about it
if Disney is just accidentally doing
this
then they are even sicker in the head I
previously thought they're crazy they're
masochists to do it
yeah it's not going to be like that old
story you know if a man ever pursues a
woman he's basically a stalker yeah we
don't have love in this movie uh that's
so dated love uh-uh no we just have cold
sterile loneliness okay that's what
people want today all right it's 2023 to
get with the program
putting aside what she's saying about
the movie
putting aside the movie which I I don't
think I'm ever going to see
you are not gonna argue this type of
person out of misery
this gets back to what we were talking
about with the 14 year old beheading
people in Mexico you will you will never
argue
you're very unlikely to argue this
person out of misery she comes out she
mocks love she seems contemptuous she
was complaining in another clip about
having to put on the costume of Snow
White this little girl gets to live out
the fantasy of so many little girls she
has to be a big movie star in one of the
most delightful little fairy tales ever
written in a remake of
one of the most iconic movies of all
time
she's complaining about it
of course
people like this
who are constantly full of resentment
and envy they're they're they're always
complaining about everything right now
go to geniusell.com Knowles YT our
friends over at genu cells sold out of
their Dark Spot Corrector and our
listeners have been begging begging like
dogs for a restock well I've got great
news just in time for the summer it's
back in stock Jamie sells famous Dark
Spot Corrector has not won but three
Cutting Edge ingredients in goes to work
fast to Target sunspots dark spots liver
spots even old discoloration both on
your face and hands you can now enjoy
your summer sun Beach and barbecues
without embarrassing spots geniusell's
most popular package also features their
summer Essentials such as the
best-selling Ultra retinol moisturizer
with a powerful retinol alternative for
safe use in the sun see results very
quickly or 100 of your money back
guaranteed go to geniusell.com Knowles
Canada
w-l-e-s-y-t right now to get your dark
spot corrector in the geniusell most
popular package that is genucel.com
knowlesyt right now save over seventy
seven zero percent off jnsl's most
popular package all orders include a
mystery luxury gift while supplies last
geniusell.com Knowles YT people like
this
who are constantly full of resentment
and envy they're they're they're always
complaining about everything
not even in a way that's constructive
like you know sometimes we'll complain
on this show like hey they're changing
the voting rules in Pennsylvania and
that's illegal and they shouldn't do
that that I hope that's constructive in
some way calling attention to a
political problem and trying to fix it
but just saying I don't want to put on
the costume love yucky men are stalkers
man you know that's that's a different
kind of complaint that's a fruitless
complaining and it's it's complaining
about
good things and trying to turn good
things to bad but you'll never argue
that person out of misery because it's
about a disposition because it's not
just about rational arguments you could
say well no actually the prince isn't
really a stalker and actually love is a
good thing and actually the Sexes are
complementary and here's why
biologically and here's why uh
spiritually and here's why it doesn't
matter it's about desire
it's about what you're attracted to
and those things are a little bit deeper
virtue cares about your feelings
politics
cares about your feelings
we are not just robots Okay we're not
just computers at various points in
history
it seems to me people
base their views of how the mind works
or how the brain works now we make
everything so physical on onto the
dominant technology at the time so a
good example of this would be when
steamboats steam engines were a dominant
technology you had a theory of the mind
coming from Freud that that viewed the
Mind as a kind of a steam engine you
know it was just you filled up then you
got blow off a little steam sometimes
that's contrary to the classical view of
the mind and virtue which is no you
don't you don't engage in Vice to blow
off a little steam so you can be more
virtuous you actually never do that
because virtue is a habit it's not just
a vice is not just a thing to be to be
uh
indulged and then blown off a little bit
that that it's it's a totally opposite
View
Vice is a thing that will create other
habits and addictions so but we changed
our theory of the mind when that was a
dominant technology now the computer is
the dominant technology so we view the
mind as just a machine I'm going to
download information we even have these
fantasies that we're going to plug our
heads into the Matrix or something like
that
the mind isn't just a computer either
because a computer doesn't have desires
chat GPT AI they don't have actual
desires human beings do have desires and
we're attracted to things and we're
going to pursue our desires whether
they're reasonable or not
we hope that those desires are in accord
with reason that's what education is
about is about is about bringing our
desires into Accord with right reason
but today
a whole generation of people more than a
whole generation has been raised to turn
their desires away from things that are
good and natural and conducive to
flourishing and toward things that are
deviant and ugly and are going to mess
them up and are going to lead them to
have miserable lives
that's where we are if you want to fix
that okay make some rational arguments
that's fine I feel the same way about
all the legal arguments about Trump
they're not they're not basing the
prosecution of the persecution of trump
on legal arguments they're doing it
based on the desire to get him and put
him in prison for over 700 years or kill
him that's what it's about so you've got
to address not just the reason but the
desire and then ideally bring the two
together
man what a great clip that was now
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles show channel see you next time